بالحديث عن الدعم العسكري الغربي المتواصل
لاوكرانيا عدا الجدل الى الساحه الغربيه
وهذه المره ليس على ارسال الدبابات بل
المقاتلات فقد تصاعد الخلاف الان حول
تسليح اوكرانيا من عدمه بطائرات مقاتله
غربيه الصنع طلباتها كياب اكثر من مره لكن
الاستجابه لهذا الطلب صعبه وحساسه وسط
مخاوف من التورك الغربي بشكل اعمق في هذه
الحرب على راسي قائمه الدول التي لم
تستبعد ارسال مقاتلات اف 16 الى اوكرانيا
كانت فرنسا حيث قال الرئيس الفرنسي من هو
الماكرون لا شيء مستبعدا من حيث المبدا
لكن ما كان شدد ايضا على انه هناك
اي قرار بهذا الشان وتجنب التصعيد حيث لا
تطول المقاتلات الاراضيه الروسيه بريطانيا
فقد حذر رئيس الوزراء ريشي سوناك من ان
رساله طائرات مقاتله لاوكرانيا امر غير
عملي في هذه اللحظه واشنطن كانت اكثر
تشددا وحسما حيه للامر حيث بدل الرئيس
الامريكي
في الحصول على اف 10 واكد انه لن يوافق
على ارسال الطائرات المقاتله الى اوكرانيا
احترام المبادئ الثلاثه اولا يجب ان لا
تؤدي مساعدتنا الى تصعيد للنزاع ثانيا يجب
ان تكون مفيده وفعاله بسرعه واخيرا يجب ان
لا تضعف قدراتنا الدفاعيه